OMAR ERLINGSSON: My
name's Omar Erlingsson.
I'm in infrastructure security.
I'm here to present the speaker
for today's special talk
with the Authors
at Google series.
So our speaker is
Gudrun Johnsen,
who is a statistician and
economist from University
of Michigan, Ann Arbor, and she
has worked for the Icelandic
Parliamentary Special
Investigation Commission
on investigating the causes
of the economic collapse that
happened in Iceland in 2008.
So for me, it's quite
a personal subject.
I'm originally from Iceland.
My family and I moved
there in 2007 from here
in Silicon Valley, where
I've been working until then.
And on a trip back,
one of my colleagues
asked me about what
were the underpinnings
of the Icelandic
economy, and I knew
that there was a lot of fish.
That's what had been there
when I was growing up,
and I knew that there
was a lot of banking,
and I didn't exactly know what.
There was some financing,
banking, stocks,
and so on, and very
soon after that,
it all came down with a bang.
95% of the market value
of the stock market
vanished overnight.
Three of the six-largest
bankruptcies in world history
are Icelandic banks, so
quite a large turn of events.
As it turned out,
what really happened
behind all of this, and this
great, rapid rise in the banks,
seems to be all kinds of
different shenanigans.
And so Gudrun is here to tell us
about those shenanigans, which,
because Iceland is
relatively small,
and because of this
completely unprecedented
special commission set up by the
Parliament, which had basically
total powers of
investigative authority,
able to see all data
everywhere, with no exceptions,
we actually know
what happened there.
But I think in a greater
context, most of us
had just moved to
Iceland, and there's
a lot of stuff that's
going on in world finance
and so on that is quite
reminiscent of the shenanigans
that were happening there a few
years ago, and I don't think,
fundamentally, very
much has changed.
So anyway, with those words,
I will give the word over
to Gudrun.
GUDRUN JOHNSEN: Thank you, Omar.
[APPLAUSE]
GUDRUN JOHNSEN: Thank you so
much, and a special thanks
to Omar for inviting me here
and organizing this event.
It's a great opportunity
for me to be here with you.
I have been giving this
talk mostly at financial
institutions and
government agencies,
but I wrote this book, "Bringing
Down the Banking System,"
as a wrapping up this 2,400-page
report that we issued that
nobody read into manageable
size of 200 pages,
but I wrote it for
non-financiers, let's say,
if there's such a word.
So it's great to finally be in
front of my targeted audience.
Now, as Omar mentioned briefly,
97% of the Icelandic banking
sector collapsed
in October 2008,
and before we entered
into the investigation
of the Special
Investigation Commission,
where I was actually
the first employee
to be hired by the Commission--
so I was there from day one
until the minute it
was published in 2012--
we sort of had an idea
why this happened.
But obviously, that wasn't
enough for the Icelandic public
to be told that that was
a result of a rapid growth
of credit, and size of the
banking balance sheets to GDP,
and inadequate
financial supervision.
I mean, that's the
short, elevator story,
but we needed to tell them
how exactly this is possible,
and how do you do this--
expanding your banking
sector from being about
1 times GDP to 10 times
GDP at the peak?
We also needed to tell them why
would you ever want to do this,
given that this is a really
risky strategy, so why would
you ever want to do this?
The third question we had
to answer was why on earth
didn't anybody stop
this development?
And finally, in my book,
I try to bring forward
to the rest of the
financial world
what we can learn
from this calamity.
Now, I will ask you to
jot down your questions.
We're going to save the best
for last-- your questions.
It's quite a lot of material.
It demands quite a
bit from the audience,
so I'll ask you to wait
with your questions
until at the very
end, unless something
is horribly vague or confusing.
Now, very briefly, on the SIC,
it was installed by Parliament,
and there were three people
appointed by the Parliament
to sit on the Commission.
There was a Supreme Court
justice, Pall Hreinsson,
Sigridur Benediktsdottir, who
was a lecturer at the Economics
Department at Yale
University at the time,
and another lawyer,
Tryggvi Gunnarsson,
who's Althingi's Ombudsman.
Althingi is the
Icelandic parliament.
Now, the mandate was not
of any insignificance.
It was to seek the truth, no
less, behind the events leading
up to the fall of
the Icelandic banks,
and what was also
quite challenging
in a small society--
and bear this in mind
throughout the lecture.
Iceland is a large
country, relatively large,
but we are only 330,000,
roughly, who live there.
So somebody told me
half of Frankfurt.
Half of Frankfurt-- that struck
me as a quite a good benchmark.
Now, the challenging part
was to basically find out
whether mistakes or
negligence had occurred
in the course of the
implementation of the laws
and other rules regulating,
or providing control for,
the financial market.
And in addition, what
persons may be responsible?
Now, the degrees of
separation in Iceland
is obviously one or two, so
this is a delicate matter.
This was a privilege to actually
be involved with this effort,
simply because the
Icelandic parliament thought
that it would be impossible to
deliver a proper investigation
without full access to all
data that the Commission deemed
necessary to deliver
on their mission.
Now, we basically had powers
to search all premises,
seize evidence
considered necessary
for the purpose of
its investigation,
subpoena witnesses.
And in return, we were to
report any suspicious contact
to the special prosecutor,
who was still working on cases
brought about as a result of
this investigation and other.
The final product was
a 2,400-page report,
published 12th of April 2010,
and the task was quite big.
We did not like the
Lehman examiner's report.
It's also 2,400 pages.
We'll go over that soon,
but just to tell you,
the scope of the research was
the third-largest bankruptcy
in history.
And we had to go
into three banks--
not only one-- and all
surveillance authorities
involved with oversight
of the financial sector.
In addition, a special
request from Parliament
was to investigate
the cross-ownership
of Icelandic firms,
and I think there,
the biggest contribution to the
rest of the world of finance
lies.
This analysis into
the cross-ownership
of Icelandic firms.
Now, we were 48 people.
We're, again, 330,000
people living in Iceland,
and it was quite
remarkable that we
were able to find people who
were not conflicted in any way.
Many of them had been
living here in the States.
Most of them had done
research, were PhDs from here
in the States-- Yale,
Stanford, and elsewhere.
So basically, with
all this data,
we collected data from the
entire financial market,
funding of the banks, all
loan portfolios of the banks,
so every single loan,
including Visa statements,
the salary data, and also, what
I'm particularly proud of-- we
gathered data from
the stock market,
and down to basically
individual investors
on both sides of
the trade-- so this
is a high-frequency dataset.
In addition to the data I
mentioned before, we also
received the entire registry
of enterprises in Iceland,
and that was essential
to be able to drill down
the cross-ownership of firms.
Now, just for the
sake of comparison,
the cost of the
investigation-- you
can find the whole
report on this.
There are selected chapters
translated in English.
2,400 pages, 800
pages supplement
online-- it took us 15
months, and the cost
was $2.5 million US.
Now, the examiner report on
the fall of Lehman Brothers
is also available online.
It is 2,200 pages.
It took them 15
months to get it done.
The cost was $38
million-plus US.
So you can see that
you can get experts
from Iceland on the cheap.
[LAUGHTER]
Now, to start answering
the questions I proposed
in the beginning--
how did this happen?
At the early start,
funding was easy,
and basically the bankers went
into the European medium-term
note market, and received
about 35 billion euros'
worth of bond issues.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, the
European what market?
GUDRUN JOHNSEN: The European
medium-term note market.
That is a standardized,
bond-issuance program.
So you see here that
the columns here
show that the
European market had
a big appetite for the
Icelandic bonds in 2005.
It dropped somewhat
in 2006, and you
see what opened up-- that was
the US medium-term note market.
It opened up for
the Icelandic banks,
simply because of this
very nice feature.
They had a stellar credit
rating that was largely
inherited by the Icelandic
state, which was virtually
debt-free at the time,
but they were also
willing to pay
high interest rates
at the level of other
emerging-market institutions
a with lower credit rating.
Now, it was as if they didn't
really think this through.
The appetite for issuing
bonds was enormous,
but they were bond issues for
three- to five-year maturity,
and in fact, the
first big payment
was too big for
them to deliver on.
So in October 2008,
Glitnir bank went
to the Central Bank of
Iceland, and basically said
that they wouldn't be
able to meet this payment,
and asked for of a loan of
last resort, and from then on,
things started to
unravel quickly.
Now, the terms were
good in the beginning,
as credit rating went
through the roof.
In 2007, they received
the highest grade,
top of the class, triple-A
rating from Moody's, which
Moody's corrected in
a couple of months.
Moody's thought that these banks
were simply too big to fail,
and would be bailed out in
whichever circumstances,
but failed to recognize
that the banks had already
exceeded the GDP, where
everything we produce
in Iceland 10 times,
so we would never
be able to bail out those banks.
Now, as you see here, it's
a nice-- here at Google,
the first thing you do
is to plot your data--
and here you see Kaupthing
five-year bond issues.
At the beginning, they are
issuing 1 billion euros.
At the time, at a rate around
20, 20 to 30, and it rapidly
grows.
Here are some peculiar outliers.
Somebody is accepting much
lower rate than the market is.
Now, we did receive our warning.
In 2006, a market
analyst started
to point out that this
rapid growth of the balance
sheets of the banks
was unsustainable,
and, well, primarily,
Danske Bank
came up with this very nice
term for it-- the geysir crisis.
And it fitted this
episode very well,
because the CDS spreads--
the Credit Default
Spreads-- they kind of blew
up, but settled down quickly
again at a lower level.
But that did not measure up to
what was to happen later on,
when the big, blue
mountain blew up,
and we had CDS spreads going
through the 1,000 mark.
Both Icelandic bankers
and officials alike
dismissed this market
signal completely,
and they claimed
that the CDS market
was marked by
collusion, ignorance--
it was a thin market,
and so on, and so forth.
And it is just as if
they didn't really
know what they
were talking about,
or they didn't really look,
because when the banks failed,
there were $70 billion
US outstanding CDS
contracts on those three banks.
And again, comparing to Lehman,
outstanding CDS contracts
on Lehman were
$72 billion, so it
was, by no means, a liquid
market, in that sense.
Of course, it's a
market with insurance,
so it's not going to behave
like stock markets, right?
Now, being faced with such
a high cost of funding,
the banks simply had to turn
elsewhere to refund the banks,
and where did they go?
They went into two directions.
One was to go to the supremely
informed central banks,
and they managed to borrow the
equivalent of 9 billion euros
at the very height.
Again, comparing to the
financial rescue package
that Iceland received from the
IMF and the rest of Scandinavia
was about 3.5 billion euros, so
a significant amount of money
they borrowed from
the central banks.
And how did they
manage to do that?
Well, they backed it with
bank bonds, to large degree.
Here you can see the
collateralized lending
from the Central
Bank of Iceland.
This is denominated in ISK,
so you can see basically
how dependent they are of this
short-term, fine-tuning funding
facility from the central bank,
so for three years, they're
completely dependent here on
the $100 billion-- at the time,
was roughly half of the
budget of the Icelandic state.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
GUDRUN JOHNSEN: Say again?
AUDIENCE: What's the
conversion [INAUDIBLE]?
GUDRUN JOHNSEN: Roughly 100.
Now, they backed it with
government-secured bonds,
but also with fellow bank
bonds, and that they did
at an increasing rate.
The central bank
acknowledged that
this collateralized lending
was getting excessive,
so they tried to stem the
funding to three banks,
but the bankers really
didn't stop at that,
so they asked a rival,
small, cooperative bank
to aid them in the process of
virtually printing money out
of the Icelandic Central Bank.
So what they did was they
issued new bonds, fresh bonds.
That's a certain interest
term, and then they
turned to the rival bank, which
received the bank bonds, which
then, again, turned to the
Central Bank of Iceland
to get liquidity out the
Central Bank of Iceland.
And the bankers reported it
to the Special Investigation
Commission that this was a
stunt that they played, and had
learned about from other
European bankers, which
is a little bit
worrying, obviously.
Now, they did try to play the
same trick on the European
Central Bank.
They placed bonds as
collateral against the loans
from the European
Central Bank, but you
see how they pick
up on it in May,
and the story goes
that the ECB basically
directed their demands towards
the governors of the Central
Bank of Iceland to have
the bankers take this out,
realizing that they
were swapping bonds.
There was no original investor
backing them at the outset,
and after awhile, they basically
disappeared from the books
as collaterals of the ECB.
Now, what they did,
though, and the amounts
were quite steep-- 4.5
billion euros they received
at the very top from the
European Central Bank--
so after having been asked to
take out the Icelandic bank
bonds, well, they replaced
them with CLOs and CDOs
that had ISK assets among them.
So collateral in ISK,
in Icelandic krona,
against the loan in euros is
not a good collateral at all,
so there's a whole
story about that.
And the Icelandic
Central Bank, in fact,
bought these CLOs from
the European Central Bank
in the year 2010, and
reported that it did
not lose anything
on the deals with
the Icelandic banks.
That was not the same story
with the Icelandic central bank,
which virtually became bankrupt,
as a result of receiving
collaterals that
they couldn't collect
after the banks had gone over.
Back to the growth, and I know
I'm cheating here a little bit.
I am showing you
here nominal growth,
but it was reported-- nominal
growth, 20-fold in seven years.
So prior to getting involved
with the Special Investigation
Commission, I was working for
the IMF, where we were studying
rapid credit growth,
and I can tell you
that it's impossible
to find data
that would show you larger
growth of any banking sector.
Now, obviously, when you
see banks grow this fast,
some people get worried.
They know that
institutional structure,
or an institutional
capacity, does not really
support this growth.
People cannot extend
credit at this fast a pace,
and ensuring that all relevant
documents have been collected,
and the credit scoring
has been proper.
So the bankers
basically pointed out,
after receiving this
criticism, that they
were growing too fast.
Well, we are diversifying.
We are getting
outside of Iceland,
acquiring new institutions,
new banks, new endeavors.
But when we looked at this, and
tried to verify this statement,
we saw that not only was the
acquisition growth large,
but the organic growth was also
quite large-- another world
record, basically.
We saw the banks
grow 50%, 60%, 35%.
This is phenomenal.
So it surely was a strain on the
institutional infrastructure.
Now, then you could
ask yourself, again
with the 330,000 people,
all of this money coming in,
what did they do with the money?
The Commission
basically was able to,
although the data that was a
little bit difficult there--
background variables
weren't properly collected--
but there are features in
the identification number,
or social security
number in Iceland,
that aided us in
categorizing the loans that
had been extended.
And we found out that
about 60% of the loan books
were to foreign entities--
so implying diversification--
and to holding
companies in 2007.
But after good cooperation
with Luxembourgian authorities,
because we didn't, obviously,
have the same data privileges
in the UK or Luxembourg
or elsewhere,
where the Icelandic
banks had operations.
We did not have any access to
data from the subsidiaries.
The Luxembourgian
authorities supplied us
with two data points,
where we could
see that the maturity of the
loan books of the subsidiaries
were also somehow
connected to ISK risk,
so dismissing this statement
that the growth was primarily
outside of the country, and at
the hands of diversification.
Now, back to that
small population,
you've got to wonder how
is it possible to extend
such an amount of credit, given
the legal constraint that one
banking institution can
only extend about 25%
of its equity base towards
a group of related parties?
Now, we think we
know how you do that,
and this is basically
how you do that.
This is the cross-ownership
of firms in Iceland.
The red dots
represent each firm,
and there are some ownership
connections to the next dot,
but these are only large firms
in Iceland, so let's say,
500 million ISK is $5
million US, roughly,
is the balance sheet of
each and every firm here.
You see where the nodes lead?
These nodes are the
banks themselves,
so this is the
interconnectedness
of the Icelandic economy
before the collapse.
Then our task was to assess
who are the related parties,
according to the
definition of the law?
And using an algorithm
and this network analysis,
we were able to assess,
or rather come up
with an unbiased methodology,
to actually find out
who were connected, and here you
see just two random examples.
And what was also a
little bit scary to see
is the circular
events that you see.
Here is a firm A that
owns firm B that owns firm
C that owns firm A. So
under these circumstances,
virtually no equity, no
skin, is put in the game.
So one of the lessons is
that if we don't properly
analyze ownership
or ownership ties
or interconnectedness
in our system,
we know that agents that play
this game simply have-- the sky
is the limit, so there's really
no limit to how much risk
they're willing to take,
because they are not
risking their own money at all.
Now, after we had identified
the related parties,
we then merged them
to the portfolios
of the banks-- the loan
portfolios-- and lo and behold,
we found out that the borrowers
were, to a large extent,
the owners of the banks.
It varied a little bit
in levels how much access
they had to their bank, but
here, this particular group,
Baugur Group, received the
equivalent of about 80%
of the equity base
of Glitnir, where
they were controlling
shareholders.
So here you see the
legal limit is 25.
They exceeded it
throughout the time.
Now, here's their
business partner,
who also gained a
controlling stake at the bank
at some point.
Somebody wants to venture
a guess when that happened?
AUDIENCE: 2007.
GUDRUN JOHNSEN: So yeah, it's
right here, in June 2007.
So as I say, it was the same
pattern in all three banks.
Here Bjorgolfur
Thor Bjorgolfsson,
one of the controlling
stakeholders,
exceeded the 25% threshold
throughout the four-year period
we had data for.
And the same goes for Exista,
controlling stakeholder
in Kaupthing bank, again,
dancing along the line
throughout the period.
Now, obviously the
loan portfolios
were marked by excessive
risk, and the next task
was to see the payment
structure of these loans,
and that was also quite
shocking to discover
that not only had
they been extended
to holding companies that
were tied to the owners
to a large degree,
but also they were not
paying anything off the loans.
They were not paying
interest rates,
and they were not paying
off any of the loan
during the lifetime of
the loan, so bullet loans
became the largest
share of the portfolios.
Then you wonder, what
type of collateral
are these borrowers
putting forward?
And that really matters.
Because we had this beautiful
data privilege and this dataset
from the stock market, and we
had also access to the bank,
so we could see what was
inside of the custodian
accounts of the banks, because
that's an old trick in the book
to have your bank hold the
stocks that you are pledged,
so your ownership is
not disclosed at all.
So what did they pledge?
Basically, to a large
degree, the banks
had received a
collateral in the form
of listed stocks in Iceland.
There is a caveat here, because
the data quality on collateral
was incredibly poor,
so this was really
the only comprehensive
data that we could receive,
in terms of collateral.
So this is a little bit
misrepresentative here,
but still we saw
that, for example,
FL Group was an investment
boutique, or investment
closed-end fund, in
fact, and about 70%
of all outstanding
shares in this firm
were pledged into
the banking sector.
To our horror, though, we saw
that about 40% of Kaupthing
was pledged into Kaupthing
as collateral, or as treasury
stocks.
Now, that is illegal.
You are only allowed,
according to Icelandic law,
to hold 10% of treasury stocks.
This is illegal in the States.
At least if you do
have treasury stocks,
you need to deduct them
from your equity base.
It's money that hasn't
been paid into the firm,
or equity that hasn't
been paid into the firm.
The following question,
after having discovered this,
we had to ask ourselves, how
did they behave in the stock
market, then, I mean,
now that they were
dependent on collaterals
from the stock market?
And lo and behold, we saw a
certain pattern there as well.
Here you see Kaupthing
trading in own shares,
and Kaupthing is buying above
0, and they are selling below 0,
and the blue line
here represents
the price of the share price
of the Kaupthing stocks.
And you immediately-- it
jumps out of the picture
that this is not
symmetric, so they
are buying close to
60% of the volume.
Of all trades in
Kaupthing, they are
on the buying side
at the very end,
but what are they doing
in terms of selling?
They're not selling anything.
So what were they then doing?
What type of business was this?
What we figured out was
that they were primarily--
you see the blue columns
here-- they are above 0,
so they are being bought
on the stock exchange,
but Kaupthing is selling
over the counter.
Now, one of my favorite pictures
in the whole 2,400 pages
is right here.
It represents the level of
leverage in the Icelandic stock
exchange.
It's a delta, so how
much are we increasing,
in terms of taking collateral
in the form of listed shares?
And as long as you are receiving
more and more collateral,
or you're accepting
more and more collateral
in the form of stocks they
are buying on the margin
more and more, you see
that the price is rising.
The red line there
leveling out--
as soon as you stop accepting
listed shares as collateral,
the price drops like a stone.
So this is virtually a picture
of an asset price bubble.
AUDIENCE: Why were they
buying [INAUDIBLE]?
GUDRUN JOHNSEN: Why
were they buying
all these shares in themselves?
Basically they had become quite
dependent on the share price,
and we will see it on
the next slide, which
added to their demise,
is that the largest
controlling
stakeholders had also
borrowed money from the big
investment houses in the US--
so Citigroup, Morgan
Stanley, and those--
and they had pledged
the Icelandic stocks
in the Icelandic
banks as collateral
against these
international loans.
Now, after the stock market
had started to decline,
the Americans basically
called on the margin,
and what the bankers in
Iceland decided then-- well,
we can't allow this to
happen, because they
will go into the market,
and sell those shares,
and what will happen with
our pool of collaterals?
It will decline.
So they decide to chip in,
and pay the margin calls,
and refund those shares that
were in themselves, accepting
their own shares as collateral.
So basically, a year
before the banks
finally collapsed,
they had become
so dependent on their
own stock prices
that they decide
to bat for life,
and take over this collateral
that is no collateral,
if they themselves go under.
Which then, again, this
would have been fine
if they had deducted the
shares that they took
as collaterals from
the equity base,
but they forgot about that.
So if we take that
into account--
and here you see we only
take that into account--
the capital adequacy
ratio that they reported
was misreported basically,
and here you see Glitnir.
It's, in fact, close to
the legal limit, which
is 8%, a year before
the bank collapsed.
For Landsbanki, it had already
gone below the 8% limit,
so there the Financial
Supervisory Authority
should have tapped in and
taken over the operations.
And if you count
cross-financing--
financing of the
rivals-- in fact,
22% of the equity is basically
funded this way, and 36%, 33%,
2008, so one third of the
equity was basically not there,
and in my mind, that is
falsification of equity,
but the report goes the route
that claiming that this is weak
equity that cannot be drawn
on in the case of bankruptcy.
Now, you've got to start
wondering why people do this,
and the short answer
is, they became rich.
Here you see the
incentive schemes
pushed for excessive
risk taking,
and just as a very
small evidence
of that is that here you see
the total share of base salary,
of total pay, in
2004 in Landsbanki.
Here's the 99th percentile,
so the CEO is placed here,
and the key personnel--
they received about 40%
in base salary in 2004.
In 2007, it's below
10%, so economists--
we have sympathy towards the
decision-making process that
happens there.
One, if you're not going to meet
your bonus target, you going
to reduce your
consumption by 90%?
No, there's is a
very strong incentive
to start manipulating
a little bit,
or extending the
evergreening loans,
and so on, and so forth--
rolling over loans,
so that the picture looks a bit
more rosy to meet the targets,
and that is exactly
what happened.
There's enough material for a
separate talk on the incentive
schemes themselves, but in
short, whether intentional
or not, the management
of the banks
used staff as vehicles
to falsify equity.
In Landsbanki, for
example, stock options
were issued one day, not as
a bargaining tool in salary
negotiations, but
one day, we have
a record within Landsbanki,
where staffers were called up,
and said, hey, you've
got an option grant now.
Please come up and sign.
And the management decided
to hatch those options,
so basically in the beginning,
they lent money into SPVs
in Cayman Islands and
offshore, lent money
to have the SPV go into the
market to buy the stocks,
and hold them until
the options were vested
or they were exercised.
Now, this is a rather unusual
and unnecessary hatch.
As I say, we can
go into depth here,
but in short, obviously
the management
decides on the timing on
when to go into the market
and buy those shares, and
what happens when you inject
into the market billions of ISK
buying stocks in Landsbanki?
Well, the price will
go up, of course,
and the options will be
in the money immediately.
Kaupthing started out with this,
but they faded out their option
program, and instead they
had their staff borrow money
from the bank to go themselves
into the stock market,
and buy the shares.
The shares were a collateral
in that loan deal,
and therefore should have been
deducted from the equity base.
Now, back to the funding side.
The banks were experiencing
incredibly high prices
on funding, or terms,
in the bond markets,
so apart from going
to central banks,
they went into the streets
of London and Amsterdam
to get money through
deposit collection,
and here you can see the
total debt of Landsbanki.
It changes rapidly.
The loans and deposits
become the largest share
of the funding structure.
Now, as it is very risky to
extend credit out rapidly,
it is also very risky to
collect deposits very rapidly,
and they tend to
be not so loyal.
And how were they ever able
to attract all these 300,000
depositors in the UK in
less than six months?
They basically offered
the highest rate.
And you're not supposed to
scrutinize this regression
analysis.
This is very crude, and you
see that there is not very much
variation here, but
basically we saw
that if Landsbanki reached the
first place, as highest deposit
rates-- they attracted about
18 million, on average, a week
into the accounts, but if it
dropped down to fifth place,
they lost 16 million, so
these were not very sticky.
It's very volatile
funding, and here
is a picture of basically outrun
on the bank that happened here
in the early of 2008.
There's a whole
story behind that,
but I will leave my
book to tell you.
AUDIENCE: Are they able
to pay those high rates
by attracting future customers?
GUDRUN JOHNSEN: So the
question is, are they
able to pay those high rates?
Well, at the end of the
day, no, of course not.
They were run upon.
Well, as they collecting, they
paid the interest rates, yes,
but it was not sustainable
model, as it turned out.
AUDIENCE: So is it sort of like
a pyramid-scheme thing, where
by offering higher
rates, we'll get
a lot of [INAUDIBLE]
customers, and we
can use [INAUDIBLE] deposits,
and pay the high rate?
[INAUDIBLE]
GUDRUN JOHNSEN: So is it
like a Ponzi scheme, where
you are giving up high rates
as you have the program open,
and then you just disappear?
Yeah, well, it was not
intended like that,
but that is the effect of it.
Now, as you can see here, here's
a random Icesave in April 2008,
and at the time, the
management of Landsbanki
reported it to the
Central Bank of Iceland
that with this
outflow, they would
survive for six more days.
The Icelandic governors of
the Central Bank of Iceland
then reported that
to the government,
to the prime minister
and the foreign minister,
and there was really no
reaction to this news.
Icesave has been the
largest foreign dispute
Iceland has had
since the Cod Wars,
and this is an ongoing saga,
and hasn't been fully resolved,
although the EFTA Court ruled on
whether the Icelandic state was
liable for the deposits, or
should pay out the deposit
insurance amount to
the foreign depositors.
The Court ruled in
favor of Iceland
basically, so we have figured
out where the liability lies
with a state or with
an insurance fund that
has been set up, and,
in fact, in this case,
the insurance fund is liable.
Now, as Lehman Brothers
failed, obviously that
proved to be an
accelerator, in terms
of deciding the fates
of the Icelandic banks.
After the collapse of
Lehman, the collaterals
that had been pledged
against loans from the ECB
fell sharply, so the ECB
started to call on the margin.
Also, the depositors in
the UK and the Netherlands
became uneasy, so they started
to withdraw their funds
from the accounts, and
essentially, Landsbanki
was run upon, and since they had
collected the Icesave deposits
into a branch, which was
under the supervision
of the Icelandic Financial
Supervisory Authority,
the Brits had very
little means to step in.
They knew that Landsbanki
was not meeting its liquidity
requirements, because the
money was just rolling out,
so they they found
no other option
except for intervening
through a legal act that
has become very
controversial in Iceland--
the so-called Terrorist
Act, whose name is,
in fact, Anti-Terrorism, Crime,
and Security Act of 2001.
So the deposits of Landsbanki
were moved out of Landsbanki,
and basically the fate of the
bank was therefore decided,
or they had met their
fate, let's say.
But we know now that the
banks had little chance,
both because they were
so interconnected,
and they had not enough
equity as a buffer
to see any of their
assets go down in value.
Now, basically Kaupthing met
the same fate a day later.
The story is a little
bit different there,
because Kaupthing adds, where
they were collecting deposits
from the UK residents
and elsewhere, was
done through a subsidiary.
And this is one of the lessons
of the Icelandic episode
is the difference between
a subsidiary and branch,
and who is responsible for
the financial oversight.
Now, the Brits were responsible
for the oversight in this case,
and after Northern Rock
had failed-- first bank
in 150 years or so
to fail in the UK--
the supervisory authority became
quite worried that there might
be other vulnerabilities
in their system,
and what they
spotted immediately
were the Icelandic banks.
And basically the Deposit
Insurance Fund was underfunded,
so the British
depositors acknowledged
that in case of failure,
it would be difficult
for them to reclaim the money.
So in all of the
circumstances-- and obviously,
bear in mind that
Lehman had just
failed-- the British had seen
some movement of funds out
of the UK over to
the US just prior
to the collapse of Lehman, the
British authorities basically
set up a very stringent
liquidity rule
against Kaupthing saying,
95% of those deposits
that you are collecting
through Kaupthing Edge--
we need you to put
them into liquid funds,
into treasuries and papers that
can be converted into cash very
quickly.
So with this rule, the
Kaupthing management
should not have been able to
use it for their own good,
but, in fact, they
managed to trick
the financial supervisory
authority in the UK
for awhile, because they
engaged in a liquidity
swap between the parent
company and the subsidiary.
So in essence, they counted
the money two or three times,
so the first time around, it
was counted as liquid money.
The second time
around it was just
their funds, which they could
do whatever with, and including
sending it up to Iceland
for the parent company
to meet their margins,
or pay off their bonds,
and so on, and so forth, and
that is exactly what happened.
Now, on top of this, so
there were 1.1 billion pounds
sterling engaged
in this, so missing
from the liquidity
pool of Kaupthing.
But on top of that,
the collateral
that they had pledged to
the subsidiary for lending
from the daughter company
declined in value,
but the subsidiary
was irrespectively
willing to extend the credit
lines by 500 million pounds,
without taking any
collateral, and this
the British interpreted
as siphoning money up
through the chain of firms,
and up to the parent company.
And as a result, having waited
for the management of Kaupthing
to react, the British
authorities deemed
it necessary to take over
the Kaupthing Edge deposits
and move them into ING,
and withdraw the bank
license from the
[INAUDIBLE] of KSF--
so a similar fate,
slightly different story.
Back to Iceland, the debt-free
state-- in early 2008,
suggestions were being made
to the Icelandic authorities
that it should turn
to the IMF for help.
That was after the
Central Bank of Iceland
had tried to get credit
or foreign-exchange
swaps with central
banks in Europe,
and even here in
America, without success.
And that is a signal
that is fairly decisive--
a debt-free state unable
to get any credit anywhere.
That should tell you
something about the situation.
The only takers in
the FX swap market
were the Scandinavian
central banks,
who, in turn, put forward very
strict conditions, in exchange
for the money swapped.
And the conditions were at the
microeconomic management level,
such as, the centrally
negotiated wages cannot
increase in real terms.
The Icelandic state cannot take
on any further debt whatsoever,
so this is very invasive type
of debt covenance, if you will.
And as it turned out, very
few people knew about it
in Iceland, and the prime
minister did not even
disclose this information
to the entire cabinet,
and as a result, he got
indicted and brought
before the special court in
Iceland that rules on breaches
on the part of ministers
in Iceland-- Landsdomur,
it's called.
So for the first time in 100
years' history of that court,
the case was
brought against him.
Now, now you know how all this
happened, and why it happened.
So the next question
is, why didn't anybody
stop this development?
And the short answer is, it was
too rapid of a credit growth,
and there were too few
people to handle all of this,
or rather, the main
cause here is, basically
the politicians
didn't acknowledge
the need for strong supervision.
If you're going to build your
economic system on the pillars
of a financial
institution's being one
of the main industries
of the economy,
well, you need to have
something to back it up,
or strong oversight, and there,
the policymakers basically
failed in Iceland.
So we had the Financial
Supervisory Authorities
doing financial
oversight of something
that was 10 times the GDP of
Iceland with only 36 employees.
And for a trained
statistician, such as myself,
it was a shock to observe
that no proper data-analysis
equipment were used.
Data was gathered in
Excel sheets of 47 sheets
from each and every
institution-- hundreds
of small and large financial
institutions in Iceland,
and this was the data
archiving and collection,
so it's impossible
to have an oversight
under these circumstances.
So Financial Supervisory
Authorities, in short, there
were lack of experience
and incompetence,
lack of proper IT systems.
Tool and processes for data
analysis weren't in place.
There was lack of
authority and follow-up.
Cases were kept too
informal for too long.
Violations of the
law went unnoticed,
and law was not enforced.
Now, the Central Bank of Iceland
did have some more insight
into the risk, and
also a legal obligation
to ensure financial
stability in the country.
It, however, never formally
or informally conveyed it
to the government what needed
to be done to avert the risk,
and had it thought that they
lacked the legal means to do
so, they did not report that
either to the government.
Now, there were a host of
tools in the policy toolbox
that could have been used,
but were, in fact, not.
So one of the lessons-- and
he put it very nicely out,
Thorarinn Petursson, senior
economist of Central Bank,
the state of affairs in
Iceland at the time--
"I think there is a fundamental
misunderstanding of what
financial supervision is
all about here in Iceland.
Not only at the FME, Financial
Supervisory Authorities,
but also the Central Bank.
They thought that the
role of these institutions
was to follow upon whether
the letter of the law
was met by those
under supervision.
So you are watching an entire
financial system falling off
a cliff, and as long as
you are following the law,
you are fine."
So one of the recommendations
of the Turner review in Britain,
which was issued
after their crisis,
is that the regulatory
and supervisory coverage
should follow the principle
of economic substance, and not
a legal form.
Just to inform you
of the losses that
were incurred after the
collapse, about five times
GDP was written off in
a matter of four or five
months after the
system collapsed,
and these delicate findings,
or the challenges that we were
faced in the beginning,
this special investigation
commission ruled that on
the mistakes or negligence
by ministers and public
officials in the period
leading up to the
collapse of the banks,
the SIC is in the
opinion that the Prime
Minister, the
Minister of Finance,
the Minister of Business
Affairs, Director
General of the FME, governors
of the Central Bank of Iceland
showed negligence within
the meaning of Article 1.1
of the law on the Special
Investigation Commission.
And as I told you before,
the prime minister
was found guilty on one count
out of four of negligence
by a special court, Landsdomur.
Now, fraud or failure
on part of the bankers
is still being decided.
Some of them have already
received a sentence
on a regional level
or a local court.
Management of Kaupthing
has been sentenced
to three to five years in
prison for fraudulent lending
practices and
market manipulation.
They have appealed.
Cases are pending against the
Landsbanki management for fraud
and market manipulation, and
Larus Welding, CEO of Glitnir,
was found guilty, but
acquitted by the Supreme Court.
Several other cases are
pending against him.
The special prosecutor had
over 200 cases in total.
58 are currently
under investigation.
20 indictments--
15 already brought
to court-- and eight
cases have been
ruled upon against
46 individuals,
so this is already exceeding
your legal efforts,
or prosecutional efforts,
looking into savings and loans
crisis in the '80s.
Now, what can we learn?
My husband is a human
factors engineer,
and he has taught me how the
human mind perceives things
inadequately, and
one of the things
is that we seem not to be
able to sense acceleration.
We all know the story when we
are going over the speed limit,
and we withdraw to
the legal limit,
we find that we are
not moving at all.
Taking this into account,
you don't put anybody
at the seat of the F-18, is it?
18, 19, 16?
Thank you-- unless he or she
has several thousand hours
in the air.
So banks are like
monstrous machines,
so you need people that
have the proper training
and the proper insight, and also
at the realm of the Financial
Supervisory Authorities.
So that said, it
is very important
that, as you do here
so well in America,
acknowledging the efforts that
go into further education,
and, yeah, that's
the aim-- to put
the right people
at the right spot.
But another lesson is
the importance of equity.
These monstrous
institutions, the banks,
are running at the
very low-equity ratio,
so there's not much
room for their assets
to move downwards at all.
This is one thing-- I
mean, now in Iceland we
have banks that are set
up, or have a funding
mix of up to 25%
equity, and it's
just that incentives
become very risky,
let's say, or people
engage in risky activities,
and it all depends on how
they are incentivized.
So if you have your own
money in an enterprise,
you behave very
differently from where
you have no money of your
own in the operation.
Another lesson is
that bankers need
to understand that when they
are lending money in the holding
companies, they have a
claim on the residual claim.
So these structures that I
showed you should theoretically
not be possible to construct,
simply because if you take
into account that
you, the bank, you
are lending the money
for the equity part,
you should price it accordingly,
so there should be no money
left on the table
for the constructors
of these structures.
So pricing obviously
failed enormously
in the Icelandic banks.
Supervision should be built
on [INAUDIBLE] substance.
We should try to have our
legal framework set up in a way
that it supports
potential policies that
need to be adjusted quickly.
The letter of the law is
obviously fairly sticky.
It's difficult to change
in a short period of time.
The medium-term
effects in Iceland--
we had massive market
manipulation on our hands.
People were not following
the legal letter.
They were evading the rules
and the law, so as a result,
we have a clear case where
the markets break down.
They just disappear, and
that is what happened.
The bond market was
virtually non-functioning.
Stock market
virtually disappeared.
There was no currency
market right after the fall,
so in de facto, we had
imposed capital controls
right after the
collapse, because nobody
wanted to trade the
Icelandic krona.
So there are a lot
of small stories
to learn from,
obviously, but I think
if there's only one that
I can leave you with,
it is that we know how our
system is interconnected.
It is a question
whether you know
how your system
is interconnected.
And now I am open for questions.
[APPLAUSE]
So to answer your
question, which
was along the lines
that, what happened
to the Icelandic people?
How many are unemployed,
and so on, and so forth.
The short answer is, we had
a spike in the unemployment
rate reaching 8%, 9%.
It has come down to
4%, roughly, now.
So we have had a history of very
low unemployment in Iceland.
I mean, most of us had
three or three or four jobs,
like you saw on my
profile, but Iceland
has been portrayed, like
here in the US media,
as a poster child of economic
recovery after the crisis.
But I have to tell
you, unfortunately,
that the judges haven't
ruled on it yet.
We have still got the most
challenge on our hand,
and that is to get
rid of the capital
controls that were
installed right after.
So, for example, if you're
traveling abroad from Iceland,
you can only bring $3,000
or so for your rental car
and your hotel, and
so on, and so forth,
so it's being sanctioned.
Currency is being sanctioned.
So net foreign direct
investment is at a historic low.
Investment, in
general, is very low,
so people are seeing
their wages have
been cut in half in real terms.
Even nominal terms
have been lowered.
Government officials,
for example,
haven't seen a raise
in eight years,
so this is a big chunk of
a person's life's work,
or of career, so we are
not part of the woods yet.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
GUDRUN JOHNSEN: They
were primarily the loans
to holding companies that
were just foam, or they were--
AUDIENCE: The holding
companies didn't
want to be [INAUDIBLE], or what?
GUDRUN JOHNSEN: Yeah, they did.
The majority of them held the
stocks of the banks themselves,
who became bankrupt, and then
you had all this domino effect.
Most firms in Iceland have
become technically bankrupt.
That has been the
most challenge that we
have been faced with after
the crash is to reorganize
and restructure the loan
portfolios of the banks,
because more than every
other loan of the portfolios
of the banks were nonperforming.
That's a very good question
on how we kept politics out
of the reporting on the
failures of the banks.
That's your question?
AUDIENCE: More or less.
I mean, we can't do that here.
How did you do it there?
GUDRUN JOHNSEN: I think that you
might see different reactions
on part of your
politicians if you
had your 97% of your
banking sector collapse.
It's just such a severity
of the situation that
did not allow for any scrutiny.
I mean, you can
wonder about reasons
why the politicians,
for example,
extended this type
of data access.
I mean, this is unheard of
that the one government that
has failed so miserably in
their policy making actually
brings on themselves
an investigation where
they can be exposed, and that
is exactly what happened.
But you've got to applaud
this type of behavior
on part of the politicians.
We're a small society.
We were a trusting bunch
before the collapse,
and one of the guests that
I had in the audience at one
of the financial
institutions pointed out
that you need a healthy dose
of mistrust in any system,
and that was lacking.
The mistrust was not
enough, but now we
swung from the totally trusting
system over to a full mistrust.
So there was a lot of scrutiny
on part of the public.
Obviously we had a pots
and pans revolution,
where people were
banging on pots and pans
in front of Parliament,
so that was not
much room for politicians
to try to cast sand
into the eyes of
the voting public.
In terms of incentives,
the question
was, what type of
prisons do you have,
where people involved in this
sentence of guilty verdict--
where can they expect
themselves to end up?
And one answer is, the length
of the sentences in Iceland
are very short, so
as it turns out,
we have had one case
of insider trading
that has been ruled upon,
and the person involved
has gone to jail for
six months total.
The sentence was two years.
If you behave well
in the prison,
you can get your sentence
halved, and then you
can do community service for
half of the remaining part,
so in this particular
instance, the expected value
was positive, so--
AUDIENCE: And the conditions
themselves are bad?
GUDRUN JOHNSEN: Oh, very nice.
[LAUGHTER]
You need to be trained to
understand acceleration
and growth and what it means.
Lawyers, for example, are
not trained in this way.
But the explanations need to be
sought in the behavioral part,
and in small society,
there's a big hurdle effect.
People were just cheering
for those bankers,
and the government officials
and the political leaders
were applauding the
people who were in charge,
and so we basically
risked being ridiculed,
and I was certainly one of those
who had been doing research
on credit growth especially.
I pointed it out a year and a
half before the banks failed,
and to tell you the truth,
there was no reaction to it
whatsoever, so
that's how that was.
Right, so what are the
capital controls that
are in place, and what
are they meant to prevent?
So they are meant to prevent a
capital outflow of the country,
so if there are claims on the
bankrupt estates, for one,
there are also foreign investors
who own ISK-denominated bonds.
They want to get
rid of their krona,
and buy foreign exchange for
it, and leave the economy,
and if people do
that massively, you
have a run on the
bank situation.
So you want to prevent
that to happen,
because if you allow that,
the currency of the krona
will devalue, and most
of mortgages in Iceland,
because we have had a history of
high inflation in our economy,
they are index-linked,
so they're
linked to the CPI index.
So if foreigners leave
rapidly, the system-- the krona
devalues, and, for example,
debt of corporates,
as well as households,
will increase, as a result.
So you will have a turbulence--
probably nonperforming loans,
et cetera, so turbulence
in the financial sector.
Financial instability is what
you are trying to prevent.
Does it answer your question?
So thank you, everybody, for
showing up here, and giving me
these great questions to
answer-- inspiring questions.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]